hey everyone I'm Alexa Ray Korea and I'm
here with one of my favorite people on
Earth design director Michael dlat hello
thank you for joining us we are looking
at the uh upcoming DLC for middlee
Shadow of Mordor um this was announced
today yep and this is you play as
letharia yeah actually so we we've got
two things we've got our announced uh
DLC so lot of the hunt our big new story
campaign coming later um but this one
the lethal skin that's actually free and
it's out now today and right now so we
can go home and download it today and
play as larel forever absolutely and um
so there's a couple of things you can
play as lethel through the campaign it's
a a skin um but also we've added a new
challenge mode which is the test of
defiance and we sort of wanted to really
kind of crank up the challenge of that
as well and sort of represent playing as
lithariel and the thing um with her
where she's a little different from
Talan is she can't rely on the power of
Kell bmore as much she can't rely on the
power of The Wraith so she doesn't come
back she's not coming back so if you die
that's it you've got you've got one life
and also she can't rely as much on the
power of The Wraith so you've got to
pick up your ammo in ammo pickups out of
the environment and you can't use the
power of domination to kind of Bend uh
the Orcs to your will and make them
fight for you but on the other hand
she's kind of kickass Warrior than
talion so she's going to do more damage
in melee uh but a bit less armor so it's
really you know it's a it's a little bit
of a different challenge um and I think
you know if you've beaten the main game
and you're looking for a real challenge
that's focused on the combat and less
around the um domination this is it so
we've got Evan here you there Evan hey
hey um that sounds brutal yeah we could
we could I love to Jump Right In she
looks so mad she's a she's uh a bit
grumpy but she's very excited to be here
she's a big grumpy just a little grumpy
now thel is the adopted daughter of
Queen marwin can you explain a little
bit for while we're getting into this
about like her backstory and where she
fits into the overall Shadow of Mordor
lore uh yeah so I guess without um spoil
out yeah too deeply but so Queen marwin
um is the leader of the the humans and
the tribesmen that are on the shore of
the Sea of ner when sauron's forces
return and she is actually kind of the
last in a long line of Corsair Raiders
they're basically Pirates so she was um
leading pirate raid throughout the
Inland sea and the sea of man um she was
tough she was and then one day you know
in the ruins of one of these ships this
little baby had survived and so she took
her own home and she raised her this
Little Orphan as her own um probably a
little bit like billb Fredo I guess but
yeah so she raised her as her own and
then so um lothario grew up among the
tribes and they also settled down and
started fortifying and trying to kind of
make a new life on the sea of ner um but
then larel grew up to kind of become the
warrior leader of the of the tribe as
well yeah she's pretty badass um for
anyone who's played shadow of mortar
she's got she's really tough she kind of
goes off on her own and does some takes
on some very large risks that talian
sort of gets on her butt for um if you
sorry if I'm spoiling anything but if
you haven't played this game already it
is your fault uh you should have
so so uh what we've got what we've got
here this is we've gone straight into
the challenge mode actually so this is
um after you've completed the story or
if you just want to go straight into it
and earn some runes that you can use to
make the main story easier but lael's
goal here is to actually Wipe Out the
orc leadership here in this part of
Mordor so to do that um oh there's one
down so that was quick you didn't even
stand a chance keep in mind you can't
get any ammo back from from um those
captains so she can still use Kell brimo
as an elf his bow skills this guy is
going to be pretty easy we'll try and
take him on in combat
maybe and also we can't brand or
dominate these guys so a big part of
talion story in Shadow Mordor is you're
actually forging your own Army to turn
against your enemies um so she can't
take that option she's going to have to
oh man look at this
guy
Walker you're a bra you think you can
take me
on and again the key to succeeding in
this challenge is uh Evan SL lithariel
can't actually die once but he's he's
doing pretty well so far now if you beat
the challenge you get a very special
room don't you so uh we do there are
exclusive and we have epic runes related
with the DLCs as well plus you're
getting all the runes for the guys that
you take down as
well and actually the
nice and that's one down um the other
thing of course is in the the other DLC
we're showing today which is the lord of
the hunt which is our other missions
we'll be going on with tovin um there's
some really powerful new runes in that
that are related to actually you know
using beasts and monsters and battling
against them as well so we're off to a
good start we've got two out of 15
captains down but we haven't yet got any
any War Chiefs six War Chiefs and 15
captains that's insane it's Madness
that's a lot and so of course the thing
with the that makes it even more
important and plus the fact that there's
no Second
Chances oh God where did his nose
go is the ever
wounded oh but there's some nice
opportunities here to use the
environment against him so if we let
those caror out oh no stop that guy
going for the
alarm okay and they can do do some of
our work for us which is
nice oh no there's more
coming oh carving get
him pop his
head but not with The Wraith mode we
just have to keep we can't so we got to
uh it's it's all down to her in this in
this challenge mode yeah we can yeah oh
that's awesome she's brutal yes wow well
she actually does more damage in melee
so um Talan of course was a Ranger he
was stationed in the gate he was you
know maybe somewhat more about um
stealth and hunting and tracking um you
know we really wanted her to be more of
a a straight up uh Warrior as well so a
little less heavily armored but actually
more damage in in combat so if you want
to play this more with you know focusing
and emphasizing the combat this the the
challenge Mode's really
fun yeah she just looks awesome now when
you were when you uh I know a lot of
players myself included were very
excited when we came upon her floating
around in the world uh when you were
creating her like what was your
inspiration for her because to me she
reads sort of like aen so was she like
you know uh aen was yeah absolutely a
big influence the the sort of The Shield
maiden and I think you know that's one
of the the greatest Parts in the whole
story of Lord of the Rings is the fact
you know when she takes out the the
witch king um especially after gandal
just had that Showdown with him and not
not being able to so you know that was
is obviously very inspiring and um I
think Arwin as she's seen in the films
and a bit more of a warrior but also I
think probably even a bigger inspiration
for us was faramir because within the
context of the story um she's really got
this relationship with her with her
mother that's very sort of conflicted
she's responsible for um this you know
entire area she's responsible for
leading all of these men trying to you
know hold on to this Kingdom as it's
being set upon by all sides by s's
forces and as we sort of I don't know
how much we should go with spoilers I'm
I'm just going to assume for the game
yeah well if someone hasn't played it
already like it's their freaking fault
they had two months too bad so spoiler
alert um but if you if obviously if you
haven't played it go out and play it and
just close your ears for a minute but um
so marwin herself is actually under the
influence of Saran at this time so again
it's somewhat like where denior is under
the influence of Sauron so she's trying
to do the right thing trying to hold it
all together but it's kind of all
falling apart around her and she's being
put in danger because of basically her
her mother's corruption to um these sort
of forces of of evil I totally did not
see San coming by the way although he
kind of that's kind of his thing right
making people do things and it's very
much I mean the theme of the whole
notion of power and the rings of power
that that we were trying to go for with
calmore as well
um and especially I think we almost oh
here we go got our first of our war
Chiefs out so this is one of
six brog the clever you should probably
check his strengths and weaknesses he's
also got one bodyguard with him we can
see but you know we really actually
within the story wanted to treat Kell
because this takes place before Lord of
the Rings it takes place before Saran
starts raising his Army of urai um so
really that idea that saran at this time
doesn't think he can find the one ring
so he's trying to get cell rimbor as the
key to the power of forging a new ring
or or getting control of that um and in
our game Kell rimbor of course is
building up his own orc Army of these
powerful urai and and and using we
obviously see the image of the hand a
lot as he's branding these guys and that
that's almost becoming a you know a
Prelude or an inspiration
later Lord of the Rings wow she's very
she does a lot of Dage yes yeah we
really wanted it to be noticeable so in
combat in melee um she's really tough
compared to
Talan oh
wow I love the braids and everything so
she why did you guys decide to go with a
skin for
luarel um I think you know out of all of
the you know we had our other six
characters in the game she was the one
that we always intended and wanted to be
the oh
nice that was awesome that was wish we
had the uh photo mode with this now
that's that would be nice
um that was nice okay one down um so you
know we had our our six characters we
had Heron who was the sort of first
other Ranger that you meet he's really
more he's more similar to to tally in
effectively um yep and then ratbag he
would be kind of f to make playable but
that that would make some challenges
with him as playable rat bag
play oh that'd be awesome I liked redbag
he was so he was a really I really
identified with his struggle to just be
the best and find a place for himself
he's so just absolutely delusional which
was fun um so really yeah out of our six
kind of story Giver character she was
always the one that was going to be the
you know the strongest Warrior out of
that group um and sort of had something
to to bring to the table and the game
play that's you know more different to
talian as well and you know I think even
even within the story we probably didn't
get as much time with her as we would
have liked to so it's great to be able
to uh come back and kind of give her her
own challenge mode where she where she
actually gets a chance to launch into
battle oh there we go so we've got the
the photo mode as well oh that's
gorgeous got that orcot oh no that's for
hair that's that's oh maybe it is Orcs
notot the nice like blood hair it's all
every every fluid it's all black I love
it this is awesome there she goes yeah
she cool also like not being able to die
kind of adds a sense of urgency to it
not being able to use the you know death
and rebirth well I think you know a
comparison I guess that um and
definitely an inspiration for the whole
Nemesis system is that idea of being
rogu like you know but rather than
randomly changing the environment in the
world it's changing your enemies um so
the other sort of I guess roog Rog like
uh aspect of the design is is making it
that you have got that one life to it as
well so this kind of a little mini uh
Rog likee version of Shadow of
Mordor we can slot some of these oh yes
Tower of defense oh wow you've got a lot
of Epic runes there oh my
God that's a lot um yes I think Evan's
clearly been practicing there's a lot of
So Def to the end um this is actually
good so one of the things with lethar oh
we jump but the the defiant Rune
actually gives you an additional last
chance so because she's not going to be
um because she hasn't got another Life
to Live she's not going to give up and S
of go down in the last chance as well
that's awesome I love the I love the
whole like Rune system of sort of
upgrading your weapons and whatnot I had
some really awesome daggers going on by
the end of my playthrough how did you
guys come up with that like when you
were just when you how did you decide
that you wanted to do sort of like a
weapon upgrade system and rather than
like leveling normally grave
um my victories are counted skull by
skull yours oh he's got and he's got the
little skulls on there so yeah is that a
head that's an actual head yes on his
head a head on his head next to the
other head that's a little inspired by
the um the the movie guy the lieutenant
oh yeah with the head on his head yes
yeah so he had to have one of those guys
but sorry back to the um the kind of
earlier question I think you know was
very much inspired by Lord of the Rings
in the sense that you know we see these
really iconic named um weapon so you
know there's sting and there's Glam
dring and there's so so on and in
particular really nice bit of attention
to detail in the films was we see when
Bilbo gets sting it hasn't got any of
the runes written on it its story is not
written on it yet and when Frodo's got
it in Lord of the Rings it has all the
runes and it's you know I'm sting bane
of spiders so that idea of actually
wanting to tell your own story have your
own um kind of Victories Mark those
victories on your we and then have that
um manifest oh wow she's oh oh my God
let are riding a
Grog yes she can yes so we're going to
let her use that bit of wraith ability
it would it would just be wrong not to
this is awesome yeah I love writing the
Grog oh you wait till um shortly after
the grows in the lord of the hun hun
they're kind of pretty massively uh
upgraded as well so we sort of went oh
what is his deal
C he look really upset I think he's
probably got a pretty legitimate reason
for that uh feeling to be honest
um it's actually pretty fun to sort of
get back to the action in this challenge
mode and not to be like of course being
a to dominate enemies bend them to your
will use them in battle for you is is
really fun in the late game but then to
sort of have that uh taken away and not
be able to use it is is kind of cool too
oh so this Gra is kind of really doing
out oh that guy had a lot of Health left
too not
anymore tends to be fairly unhealthy wow
she's really powerful this is
exciting this is very exciting to me is
he is that oh he did he eat someone yes
uh he actually get he gets Health back
as he eats people as well um the the
other grag we're going to meet later
does even more than get his health back
he actually builds up an ability to
start ooh projectile vomiting over
everyone so we'll hop back on him
projectile
vomiting
nice that's cool so oh we got one we
need to go after another
Warchief we check the uh the Army yeah
much go the hardest one there go get
what are their names let's pick one
based on the name the flogger M yeah get
the other if you go gum the unmovable so
this guy theer the fun thing with he's
got five bodyguards as well so if we see
his strengths and
weaknesses um he's a good leader so he's
going to have more bodyguards so if we
go after him we can simultaneously take
down well I say we I mean Evan can
simultaneously take down a bunch of
captains and a war chief at the same
time so let's see how that keeping in
mind that we can't die that's going to
be fine isn't it we can't don't die you
don't want to embarrass
yourself the no this is free
is free and this is available today yep
awesome yes yeah we've really I mean uh
we've had a number of sort of free DLCs
and different skins now we've had the
captain captain of the watch and we've
had dark talion the black black yeah the
black hand he was fun as well I think um
lariel out of all of them's probably my
favorite as well because she's really
you know it's not just the Cosmetics of
the skin she actually is rebalanced and
in particular in the challenge mode it
really is a different sort of play style
to the
combat
yeah Okay so we've got to infiltrating
people are talking in the chat about it
but this is free but Lord of The Hunt is
pay DLC part of the season pass yes
exactly and that's a full new campaign
so there's you know more than 10
missions in that and that's sort of
hours of gameplay and a bunch of new
features that we'll see later so
combination yeah we'll get there we'll
get there but this is really nice so
she's we're going after a Warchief and
five body guards simultaneously what
have we got
wow gosh and those are a lot of uh a lot
of extra like those are like the the sub
achievements or like other like um I'm
totally blanking on the word yeah so uh
optional optional objectives optional
objectives damn objectives that was what
I was looking
for so and they're around um so the
score is like basically the score
substitutes for experience points so
anything you do to increase your
experience so it's more variety in
combat more different sorts of takedowns
using strength and weak like all sort of
things he tried to crawl away and she
pulled him back yep no mercy
wow yes ner was a lovely place before
they uh before they showed up so she's
pretty unforgiving about
that what we need to do here oh man this
is actually a stealth objective so we've
got to sneak
in animations work really nicely on her
I
think okay and then once we reach um
this Viewpoint that's going to draw out
the Warchief and there's some ammo up
here as well oh man they're all together
it's like a
party a party of death I love that they
chant the name of the war chief when he
comes in the chants were great because I
mean obviously there's hundreds of names
but even so in the scheme of things you
know they um they were relatively easy
they're also enormously fun because we
just got to get like a big bunch of
people together and just name the start
screaming chant and also doing the uh
the drinking songs were fun as well oh
yeah the drinking songs um oh evil eye
can we talk about naming Orcs for a
minute how do you guys name them there's
so many of them yeah you guys have like
all have a name have a lore person yeah
so we have U we actually have quite a
few different um l experts that we we
work with there's um a professor a
talking scholar Janet Croft it's really
great and there's another uh guy called
David Salo and he was the uh language
consultant for the films as well so we
work with him a lot as well um and then
of course there's all the the references
within the within the books um and then
we sort of have fun doing it as well the
other thing of course we did with the
Orcs is it's not just the name but then
the titles as well so we really took
that kind of inspiration from the
Vikings and from barbarians of of giving
them different titles that relate to
their strengths and weaknesses or their
personality so oh get him chase him down
let no one live is he get him get him
not today you're not getting
away his
head end oh he's philosophical well
that's uh I love that after all this
time I still get to see and hear lines
that you know haven't actually heard in
playing before and I've been looking at
this for hundreds hours yeah I I I just
don't
know I don't think they even know but
enough though yeah we still see new
stuff which is great that's awesome I
love I was telling I think we were
talking about this earlier one orc very
insinuated that he would like to keep
caragor cages for insidious purposes and
he every time I ran up to him he'd be
like you're back to play he was my
Nemesis and I killed him and it was sad
but that's that's what's so like some of
the relation especially once you get um
domination some of the relationships
that really start off as being about
revenge I'm going to get this guy and
then they sort of build into this state
of kind of almost uh affection I think
cuz they so and I think this was a huge
part of of the writing as well um so as
mentioned before you know Dan Abnet one
of our writers who wrote the you know
the comic of Guardians of the Galaxy and
a bunch of stuff the fact that there's
some humor in
there you butcher oh he's accus get him
he's down yeah gone dead bye boom pH
mode oh my god get that
yes amazing oh that's greatt that's
great that's awesome oh nice get go a
bit ay with this one do you like a sepia
color is there seia situation there is
CPO
oh oh man oh perfect this is
perfect I'll hang that on my wall That's
nice and the photo mode of course is's
another free um download too so it's
fun yeah people really start to like
these guys and so you yeah you start off
after revenge and then he sort of
becomes part of your your team and
there's sort of a affection for them my
guy's name was his he was posha the frog
blood and he was green and and I will
never forget him like Kermit yeah he was
like a big fat green Kermit he was just
a big rotund like he had like like a a
like a like just straps over his front
and like a little shoulder pad we you
know we hated each other oh he just got
promoted not today not for long nope oh
oh that's great oh nice that's awesome
he just got a trophy as well are there
more trophies with the
um not with the free one but
absolutely yeah yeah with Lord of The
Hunt as well
um three out of six we're halfway there
and nearly all the captains so to see we
have a a question Bob Jones 1980 wants
to know if there is more dialogue added
into the
DLC um not into the not into the free
one the hunt yes but with lord of the
hunt and of course with our other our
other main story DLC which will be the
bright Lord so
the Cali DLC oh my gosh I cannot wait
for that that is
awesome without without spoiling
anything yeah so actually some of the
new uh which of course we're going to
get to shortly but some of the new war
Chiefs and new Warchief we've added new
WarChiefs and new Warchief abilities in
The Lord of the hunt so some of those
are are pretty
fun I'm surprised she hasn't gotten
super mobbed yet some of my uh most
challenging and rewarding moments in
this game where you're in a situation
like this and you start fighting two
people and it's kind of happening and
then all of a sudden like 30 more Orcs
come out of nowhere and you're just
bouncing between like fighting them I
love that it's uh yeah actually um Evan
here's being pretty methodical about
making sure none of them Reach the alarm
um so yeah once that kicks off it's like
done things can get pretty chaotic oh
some flow what she pick up Al barfa the
cruel is our next Target yes Bara the
cruel I like that barfa oh didn't didn't
kick that slave don't let him do
that oh
man who's your next uh who's our next
war chief we're going for let's get
barfa I vote for Bara okay he's around
here somewhere he's he's a Mia
Captain one out of oh you've got you've
created one problem for yourself there
Evan which is that um when you kill six
War Chiefs you you've got actually got
four War Chiefs I think on the pedestals
in the hierarchy can you just go and
check oh so you're not going to be able
to get gold one of those other guys got
promoted
uhoh uhoh it's
fine still can still beat this okay we
need to choose another we should choose
another war chief here this is so involv
D she's got to work cut out for her yes
and uh I mean obviously Evan's pretty
capable as well so he's he's making this
look relatively straightforward who is
that guy the nightbringer Shaka
nightbringer let's go in and check him
out Shaka oh he's got like a thief mask
on yeah he's going to be stealthy let's
check out his strengths and weaknesses
so he does have some fears Furious
battle and with that light armor he's
fast as well so if he does break and run
he's got a pretty good chance of
escaping especially with these other two
bodyguards we can do it we can get I
know I know we get them leave no orc
alive he's a good chances to up the
score as well just sort of that
incidentally um being a to take guys out
as we go past oh that's awesome get
him oh he's not coming back from that
okay go
lario
and there's his mission icon over there
oh he's back in the um hanging out back
in the shanty as well there's a a lot of
runes there sort of building up on the
map we could come back to and collect
later as
well cool there's a lot there's a lot
going on here yeah that's I mean again
even from the point of view of of
showing it all the streams the fact that
you get to see something different every
single time we're looking at it it's fun
as well they tend to get sort of lost
and caught up in what's going on that's
the okay so to draw out this guy really
need it's going to be a rampage and in
under two minutes as
well she actually shouldn't have too
much trouble with that this is going to
be a blood bath yes this is actually a
case where letting the alarm go off
first can be a benefit cuz that's going
to mean there's going to be even more um
enemies swarming in so you can see
actually keeping these alive because the
counter the two-minute counter starts
after the first guy dies so one's dead
so now we've got 2 minutes to kill more
two are
dead 18 to go this will be three are
dead have to be a bit careful about
getting hit here she's actually got less
armor than talian as
well oh wow five are dead she's very
strong yeah she does significantly more
damage on the on the melee as well
because again you can't rely as much on
on um Kell bmo's range because she's not
able to to reather ammo from uh oh she
did it that's my favorite move ever head
Pop I love the head
Pop there's just something so satisfying
about like stabbing an orc and then just
going and then their head
explodes the other one one of my my
favorite Rune is the uh there one that
on the quick throws has a chance to just
basically make guys explode each time uh
you hit them so that has to be fun as
well there are a couple of really
awesome abilities when you get farther
down in the ability tree
noio get her get oh okay we have got
that other Rune madad how dare you
that's before the Warchief even gets
here too she is so pissed her hell slow
too so
pissed oh god oh this is this is getting
real oh my
God okay one more and then the Ws out
okay he has arrived so the night bring
is now going to arrive with his two
bodyguards as well sh oh bodyguard he's
got with those that Berserker looks
pretty tough behind him
feathers oh my God be
careful now I can't remember seeing a
lot of weaknesses on um the nightbringer
other than a fear of
fire but he's also fast so that's going
to be interesting cuz one of the ways to
kind of strip away some of his strengths
is going to make be to make him flee in
Terror but if we do that he's got a
pretty good chance of escaping as well
oh man even star oh that's
cute blade of gondolin wow these are
when you've got a bunch of these epic
ones stacked up they're pretty
powerful no hammer what's you
choosing what are you going for here
ruination oh they they're powerful so
they um there's a lot of Epic ruins I
didn't realize there were that many wow
and then they show you like the dying
moments of like the orc that you that's
the guy that you defeated in order to
actually gain that particular Rune so
it's a nice little dead momento that was
the other inspiration for those as you
know as well as a lot of the Rings as
kind of the the kill markers on the side
of fighter jets or
whatever okay it's on
now oh well he looks cool g the
vile one
down oh
man vulnerable to M oh ranged as well so
this is going to be another nicely
placed head shot and this is
Slayer but what king did he slay I'm
sure he'll tell us if if we get close
enough
wow all right that knowledge dies with
him although you know he could be back
from that with a scar but not in um not
right now not in this because of course
she can't die so time's not going to
come you know move forward here so
sometimes if you kill you kill an orc
they might return with a scar yeah so we
really I mean there were two parts of
that one unless you behead them if their
heads are off that's it they're done not
not withstanding a couple of small bugs
that show up very rarely but um but yeah
the two things one we wanted them to be
extremely tough and it you know very is
very much is a Hallmark of villains that
you think they're dead but they're back
so and we know if you've had a
particular relationship with a guy if if
you've encountered him a lot if he is
kind of your Nemesis so it's not just
random we're choosing the guys who we
really want to elevate and become these
kind of personal uh villains oh man you
were so close to finishing two captains
and three War Chiefs
left and one of the Warchief positions
is
empty oh come on you got
this Health's down this is not an easy
fight he's nearly down he's waiting
finish him before he gets my gosh get
him Darkness fors he's like really
philosophical final yeah I like some of
the last words and they can either you
know because we don't really know what
the lifespan of the hood popped off his
hood popped off he unasked so we could
see look at that guy at the back he was
like he was just so
confused was like what this is I got up
this morning this is not what I expected
oh my gosh it's all gone wrong okay
we've got two more two more war Chiefs
before the Lord of The Hunt I love when
the um I love when the Orcs uh run from
you when you show up and they're like
grave Walker and they like run away and
really screaming escalates through the
course of the game so as your Legends
growing and they start talking about you
more you know because you showing up
more in in their conversations their
fears see that other epic Rune I don't
if you know the little shaking uh hit
counter number there that's because one
of the Epic runes actually lets you
maintain your hit counter for longer so
you can use a lot more of those powerful
abilities so the you know the the big
area effects um that's useful that's a
powerful one that one makes a big
difference next free skin some of the
the chat is hoping that that rat bag r R
bag skin maybe one
day they love rat bag the fans love rat
bag the fan I mean and we're fans
obviously like the team loves rat bag as
well he be what made you decide to like
make rat bag like what was the idea
behind him I think I mean it was a it
was a combination of um a lot of
different things you know one we needed
someone who bought together the Living
World of the Nemesis system you know
with the story um do I think you know
we're in Mordor this place is it's
pretty dark it's pretty violent um it's
the sort of dark heart of of Middle
Earth so having some humor to lighten
that I think was really very very
important as well and you know we didn't
want anyone to I think think of our Orcs
as like just Orcs we wanted to be really
clear that they have personalities and
their characters as well so yeah really
want like an orc with a strong
personality someone who's bringing some
humor into it and someone who's really
uh kind of connecting the story in the
Nemesis system as well and I think he
does all those three things uh pretty
well and um Phil Lamar who who played
him just did like an amazing job that's
the other thing with rap EG I think we
had our sort of hopes and goals and and
as he was written um but he he was I
think brought to life to a level that
sort of went above and beyond that as
well I heard a story uh the scene where
he's in the they show it in the trailer
where he's sort of swinging that he like
you actually put him on ropes and did
the capture with him like yeah sadism
AES I think sadism was a very very
important component of all of the oh we
had this is actually this guy is one of
the the sort of best friends of the
Warchief in this area so his screams for
help are what's actually going to draw
out the war chief to come and help him
wow
W that's awesome oh the poet oh this guy
let's see just how poetic he's
feeling oh man
man orc poetry is um bye a a
variable they have their own culture
their own
art they really
do
finally oh he's looking up Bara is here
yes oh we wanted Bara and now here he is
we've got barfa we've got zadra that's
two there were only two left right he
should have actually you know what he
should have had he should have had
actually rhyming um bodyguards that
would have been more appropriate for the
poet okay
oh wa oh my God this
is she's so mad right now she is real so
he's
done yes it's actually I thought I
thought uh Evan was kind of going to
have a walk in the park with this but
this is tough there's a bit of tension
oh and he's enraged the poet is enraged
probably due to the death of one of his
bodyguards yes hate of bodyguard
suffering he really is a warrior poet
this guy forget him come get up close
and personal with me instead okay okay
so he's very angry about the death of
his bodyguard but he's also uh ready to
move
on oh my god oh so close I want to hear
his last words he should get it the poet
has to have something uh poetic to
observe as his as his final
words oh God you're so close oh you know
what else we should have done we so
should have let you replay the final
words in the um in the Rune page when
you could go back and look at those guys
oh yeah great oh no oh my God don't
don't die don't do it
larel I think I mentioned she does get
actually more last chances than Italian
oh which she's definitely going to need
here oh my God don't
oh God she's
pissed let me take him Master I'll make
him s God the Orcs not very good about
gender no it's it's not a big thing in
their society are there female Orcs
there are not so where where're sort of
um these Orcs these URS uh they're drawn
from the same sort of cut from the same
cloth I should say as saran's urai so
they're they're pulled from the sort of
birthing Vats under barer and BN in mud
yes and drawn forth now in uh in tolken
wrote that they are they were once or
began as elves and they were corrupted
by the first dark hord yep so this has
been going on for some time Yeah you
sort of and so some of these guys could
be really old as well you know they
could they could have been around it is
my own blood that will
interesting
um and certainly
bye Captain down um they have got the
pointed ears of the elves as well so
we've sort of followed you know followed
that lineage
here and that sort of relates to to Kell
Bimbo's perception of them as well so he
as an elf you know particularly when
he's starting to think about dominating
them and making his own Army from his
point of view he's almost redeeming them
he's kind of taking them back and
undoing what the first Dark Lord did
he's a cal is a little grumpy he's a
little
grumpy he's he's more than a little yeah
it's it's
like taker rhy stealer there we go oh
he's just sad that he's not going to
make any more poems rhyme stealer that
sort of hurts yeah yes the poet is no no
more so we've got one more war chief to
kill
yes nice yeah I think in a way Kell bmbo
is actually the one even more than
talian who ultimately is really corrupt
you know more corrupted by the there was
a um can't remember where I read it but
but someone in in looking at the game I
think really did deconstruct very
successfully that actually Kell Kell
bmbo kind of is the San of of this story
he is the sort ofy that is trying to you
know fight the power of saon with power
that is kind of somewhat using um talion
and dragging him along you know in much
the same way as the ring is trying to
sort of has its own mind and is's trying
to drag people along with it yeah it's
using the weapon of the enemy yes yeah
which yeah so kind of remember was
interesting like that I think the he's
sort of the
villain but believing that he's doing it
very much for the right reasons um and
also you know very much with a I think a
personal notion of of Vengeance as well
so the fact that he had for hundreds of
years this personal relationship with
Sauron as well yeah they were pretty
they were besties we were pretty close I
mean I'd be mad too if I found out that
my best friend that I was making jewelry
with actually is the dark lord incarnate
yeah who wouldn't and then then killed
my family and chained me up I'd be
really upset
so I feel
it I love relation but they work
together for so there's definitely
there's a LoveHate um component to it
for
sure I love the uh relationship between
kellmore and talion because talion is
sort of that like con like he's a little
bit conflicted and a little Angy and
Kelvin more will show up and be like
he'll like pop into existence and be
like hey you got to go do that yeah
gross yeah he's offering it's just like
rereading Lord of the Rings at the
moment and there's the moment when you
know Sam um has to take the ring off
froto and he's sitting up you know he's
on the edge of Mordor and his head's
just totally filled with fantasies of
raising an army and conquering M so you
know I think that's that's very very
much what Kell [__] is doing to to talion
as
well this she'll be fine here the trick
to draw this guy out is we've got to
take no damage so that's going to mean
using every uh weapon this one's
actually probably a little bit
harder for her than it would be for
Talan um because she can't rely as much
on on the race P but you seem to be
doing pretty well Vermillion 3 would
like to know if you can use her skin in
the main campaign yes yes you can
absolutely awesome um and the and the
Rune the Epic Rune that you gain from
this as well I imagine that that uh epic
Rune would be helpful in uh the upcoming
DLC we're going to look after this which
is the the lord of the hunt with some
pretty nasty
vs jaws of death oh
nice well another
Trophy this was actually
the um one the first games I got my
platinum trophy on so that was
fun yeah and so there's there's new
trophies as well with that DLC as well
oh good and we'll be taking a look at
that once we get our last war chief oh
we've only got one to go this is it one
war chief just we've just got to make
sure we take no damage here oh this is
great so actually
oh holy
crap I was just about to say how
absolutely brilliant that strategy was
of uh unleashing all those caragors and
uh letting them do your work for you by
rampaging through the the stronghold
slaughtering these guys but did we we
didn't fail the power of defiance did
we just simply failed to uh draw out
that War I wonder if we should how
quickly do you reckon you can go after
him again or should we pick another oh
we we'll do them again this will be fine
how long have we I don't even know what
that time is actually Key Master 610 is
wondering if we're going to get um it
seems to be that bathing suit costume
DLC is a popular thing and if we'll be
getting a talian and underwear skin is
that a popular thing I yeah I mean
they're doing it for Smash Brothers they
have one guy in like a bathing suit and
then there's like I don't know would we
get a lifestyle Italian bathing suit
that's it it it hasn't come up to this
point that's the first maybe we
should interesting that's a project for
uh for modders for the PC version I
would totally buy a Italian and
underwear skin off of somebody just
saying
yeah all over that interesting yeah yeah
there's there's those they're probably
is a cosplay of it already somewhere oh
don't get hit don't get hit oh
gosh
that's a new move pulling on them yeah
we had they try to run away yep
wow yeah the animators just did she's
rough such a great job I think the other
one I mean of course we'll see in the
other DLCs but and then the the bright
Lord as well where um we actually get to
play as Kell rmbo they've really gone
back and gone right through so you know
his fighting style feels really really
different again so that's awesome I know
that I like that uh talian had a little
bit of Grace to his flipping around and
stuff but she's just straight up brutal
she's
great oh my God you're so
close Okay halfway we're almost there we
going to do
this win that b oh my God I'm getting
really
nervous I can't watch take any damage
okay I'm getting so nervous nine to
go we we got ammo we still got ammo Oh
Yes
actually so we have to kill 20 IRS
without taking damage and then that
draws out the war and that's going to
draw out the war chief and that's going
to be six out of six oh my God don't
take damage we should have recorded this
earlier I can't watch it live this is
nering yeah oh God not him no get him
okay
okay yeah they're not being able to die
they not have because obviously in the
main game the death and Resurrection is
such a sort of a key part of the loop
and of Kell bmo's power so taking that
away and having the tension of not even
being able to die once just changes the
the feeling of the whole thing I really
love this this challenge mode it's fun
you did it okay this is it this is it
the immovable I he look
easy okay you've already done the
captains so this is it so all you got to
do is take him down yep
vulnerable easy do it get it get it get
it boom yes
Bravo well done amazing holy
crap that was incredible and that's
awesome she so that's out today yep
that's free that's juste free take it
jump on your console of choice play as
larel join the madness
now we are going to look at now this is
the first DL paid DLC for the season
pass yep uh Lord of The Hunt it's uh a
beast hunting campaign and it stars my
favorite side character torvin the dwarf
this is this is so exciting I love
dwarves they're my f probably my
favorite uh of the middlee races I've
going to say Orcs I got to dispute with
you there oh you you like you L the or I
mean you made a whole game about it that
is true and you're using we are using
this is the costume skin that comes with
it yep so this is the Beast Master skin
and again so you get the skin for this
campaign beard going on right here he
yeah yeah he's he's got a wait till you
see the mullet it's amazing oh there's a
mullet oh yep and um and but as well so
you can use this skin throughout the
main story campaign as well as in the uh
Lord of The Hunt campaign as well so
there's there's a bunch of um new stuff
in there so there's new war Chiefs um
there's new creatures and beasts both
for you to fight against but also
they've got new hours that you can use
in combat um and there's the Epic runes
and there's plenty of new time to spend
with uh with tovin as well and more
Collectibles and lore to kind of uncover
more of his backstory as well for
another one of your HTS Master dwarf but
this is your hunt captain Oh my God this
is there's a park of War Chiefs just
arrived in N call themselves Beast
Masters Beast Masters that does sound
like my kind of prey what do I need to
know I know you're familiar with the
carar I taught you everything you know
about but let me tell
you oh I see the
mullet oh look at
itay ATT oh my gosh oh
yeah look at that so he's really sort of
embraced the Wilderness and the monsters
and the Beast this is all about them and
this takes place um During the period
when you're when you're in ner a sea of
ner and as this is kind of um as talion
been stirring things up and stirring up
these creatures Sauron determined that
he basically sent out these really Elite
War Chiefs as exterminators to either
kill or tame these monsters but being
Mordor sort of nature itself responded
to this and the the creatures themselves
have kind of uh increased in power as
well so it's a combination of trying to
take down these new Beast Masters as
well as battling against these new
monsters and then kind of as as with so
many things of being Behind Enemy Lines
in Mordor turning all of these different
foes against each other and and kind of
turning your enemies against each other
oh Mordor so these guys I really like
these guys so basically the caragors the
big cats we had in the main game was
sort of like lions the big Alpha
Predators they're Hunters carath carag
gath which means um Jaws of of death
these are stealthier um so basically
they're more like a panther and what's
fun with that which I don't I can't
actually ever remember doing this before
in a game but you've got you're mounted
but because it's a be cat you've got
stealth while you're mounted so you can
actually stalk your enemies while
mounted hide in the bushes and actually
pounce on them and kind of maul them to
death from the back of these uh big cats
and they're also they're like a Jaguar
they'll like crush the skull in one bite
as well oh man um Bob Jones 1980 would
like to know how many new creatures you
added and if we could maybe talk about
them or are we going to run into all of
them yeah yeah we'll probably get a
chance to to see um most of them the the
two biggest ones the two ones with the
most of definitely the the carigas and
The Wretched Grog and the thing with
them wretched Grog with both of them is
we really wanted to add more than just a
challenge for you fighting against them
um but also you know really this ability
for you to use them in the sandbox yeah
so they've got so now we've got big cat
stealth kills which are that's awesome
one crunch on their skull we should get
some photo mode action on that as well
yes please now these and the funny that
you can do like the death from below so
you got Archer you can actually Sleek up
below the tower and kind of grab them
off so so these new The Wretched Grog
and the carath are they only available
in this DLC or will they now show up
okay so they're these are yeah these are
in the in the DLC DLC wow look at that
oh we need some photo mode action on
that stealth
kill oh he's yeah he's waiting he's not
so big under the under the
sneaking oh man he one more with a
stealth kill then we got to take these
guys out oh
that's didn't even know what hit him oh
get get the Jaws get like can you get
get the jaws and the mullet in one shot
can we get it all in there oh
man can we get the mullet no okay the
mullet's a little little I love that
mullet it's very Dwarven yeah it's very
inspired by speaking of uh dwarves
Corvin is we've never really seen a half
naked dwarf before uh he's sort of
doesn't really wear a lot of armor and
his hair's his hairing beard are short
like all the dwarves that you know
modern media have shown us like Thorin
and everyone have like the big long
braided beard so when you were designing
Torin whoa
what oh my when you were designing
Tarvin like why did you start to you
know sort of give him a little more of a
I don't want to say clean cut would that
be clean cut for a dwarf that would be
extremely clean cut that would almost be
basically he's like a skin head by dwar
standard he's like totally skin head uh
clean you know very much clean shaving
and I think the thing with tvin as well
like again it comes back to thinking
okay we're in we're in Mordor we're in
this place that's obviously here he is
there he is we'll let let you tell him
yourself let him talk for a minute their
plans are in disarray there still work
to be done to ensure the Uruk never tame
the caragan the war chief the Beast
Tamer a that unnatural fiend needs to be
put down to draw him out use the carath
against his War Camp the more uru by
their shadowy b means bu it yep so it's
really about using these creatures to
draw out the the war chief and then if
we zoom in then the actual War Chiefs
themselves you know we've got sort of
obviously a lot more um their armor
their equipment but also their strengths
and weaknesses as well so if we their
power is very high yes uh they're really
they're really powerful really strong in
combat and they actually get some um
some new traits they can use in combat
as well so this guy basically the trick
with him is to use the stealth of the
the carath against him because um if we
don't succeed in that and he sees us
coming he's going to be extremely
powerful in in combat so can't shoot him
really powerful in combat and he's going
to kill our carag so we could either now
we could either go after him um and his
body on his thing oh that's awesome and
uh alternatively we could go and do
another mission with tovin and learn
more about one of the other creatures
and kind sort of draw them out can we do
another mission with torvin all right
let's go yay so torvin actually has a
really interesting um origin story I
know we've talked about this before he
sort of your Inspirations for him have
come from some very yeah so yeah I got
distracted by toen there before but um
yeah let's go for that one we'll go oh
we'll go see the uh the mounted ones as
yeah we'll go for this one we'll get us
through as many as we can we've got how
much time we got some time we got some
time oh good yeah um so we're in Mordor
um clearly this is a long way from
arabor a long way from you know where
dwarves would normally be found so any
dwarf who's here is already going to be
slightly
mad um yeah so you know we knew he was
going to be an outsider he was going to
be someone who was very much kind of on
the fringes of of orc society and and
then we see that the the sort of dwarves
we do see like we still wanted him to be
faithful to that as well we see them
hunting the dragon we see them as
Hunters they're very militaristic so
really inspired as this guy who was an
outsider a loner a long way from sort of
or society and very much in the idea of
a Hunter cuz we wanted Mordor to be this
wild um place so he was kind of I gu I
think um you know one of the big
Inspirations we had as okay who is this
ultimate kind of Big Game Hunter oh man
so there was quint in jaws of course was
a huge reference right down to some of
the facial hair and I've forgotten the
guy's name the guy in Jurassic Park who
was the big game hunter was actually
pretty cool as well but we really wanted
that idea of him being this loner this
big game hunter someone who could
introduce you to to to how to do that
and how to use these creatures and Hunt
these creatures nice sorry some of the
kills make me laugh um that's awesome so
he's he is the Quint of of Mordor he is
the Quint of Mordor little dash of
Wolverine and and he was really fun he
was one of the first sort of characters
that we worked with WETA on the design
of as well so oh wow um they sort of had
a lot of you know a lot of that I guess
attention to detail on his on his
equipment and on his sort of gear so
damn that's awesome um who's his
bloodline he's from he's Jan's um is he
Jan yeah he is from he is from the north
and he actually came here like some of
the law and stuff we learn about uh he
actually came here hunting with with his
brother yeah but of course that didn't
turn out so well and then something else
that we've got in um in this DLC is the
ability to explore more and basically
uncover Tobin's journals and learn more
of his sort of backstory and his history
and some of his kind of Tales you know
around hunting these different creatures
as well that's exciting to me as a l
Hound that makes me incredibly happy um
Bob Jones in 1980 popping out all the
questions today um do all of the war
Chiefs are in this DLC are they all
related to the new creatures yes okay
yep so we you know there's the the sort
of five new these super Elite War Chiefs
um the completely new Showdown missions
to take them down New Missions around
the creatures to bring them
out 1980 you're on fire today thanks for
all the questions so this is actually
quite fun as well so in addition um
let's let's just track these guys down
so again torin's helping us out here oh
this is another new ability we get so
one of the Fe when we're when we're
running um you can use opportunities in
the environment if you mantle over them
you can get a speed burst and so
basically to make the navigation on
these carag gas more interesting and
speed them up we've now got that on the
on the cars as well so that lets us
actually you know race around and
Traverse the Traverse the world even
faster than the the caragors could and
that's the key in some of these missions
we've got to intercept these guys
quickly no time
toare as I can now there is uh there's
no release date for this for this yet
it's coming out this year so it's not
not far away all right so we'll be
getting it soon it's going to make it
we've got to reach this uh Reach This
Hideout quickly
okay and um Cal sash wants to know about
how long this DLC is like or how much
content is in this is in Lord Of The
Hunt it's
um it's a
good I mean you know through through
play testing If you're sort of going
through it pretty quickly sort of three
to 3 to four hours so if you're
exploring and playing around more and
exploring the Nemesis system and mocking
around with the new creatures of course
it can be uh a lot longer and then of
course with the season pass we've got
two of these full campaign ones as well
so talking bunch of and the thing that
you do get um from this one as well the
Epic every one of those War Chiefs has
an exclusive epic Rune and then they can
carry back into the the main campaign as
well people in the chat are also asking
about a Torin skin I guess torvin is
also popular yes torvin and rap egg so
we've got a we've got a lisco on here
we've got tovin rap bag and a bikini and
Italian in a in a bikini or how whatever
they would wear in Middle Earth to swi
in oh quick come on what are you doing
no you got 10 seconds man Grace you've
done so well oh man you can do this you
can do this you got it where you going
what oh damn why did you do that a he
was using the it was brilliant you just
added to the it was like smoking in the
Bandit
amazing um so we have to intercept these
guys before they before they escape
damn yeah so it's nice oh oh that's so
good the audio audio guys just did a
great job the audio this is pretty great
I think maybe the highlight of the audio
will'll get to later was when the uh if
we get to hear the the grow start
vomiting on people with my brother's ax
a small victory there's no trace of the
blasting powder anywhere something that
valuable only the smuggles is good I
like this guy his dark master has better
blown up and Wast I like that his
here's car there the little Enemy Lines
on it floing above it I like
her
um Ruku 5150 will this DLC add any new
abilities and
Powers uh yes so it's adding so yeah and
especially all the powers while you're
mounted so you can move faster while
you're mounted you can stealth kill
while you're mounted we've got the range
um and then actually there's a bunch and
then when we get to the the ghouls you
can actually start summoning them
yourself there are in this one too yeah
but you can you can actually lead them
and summon them so you can kind of make
your own horrendous ghoul Army so
basically every single one of these
missions is bringing in some big new
mechanic or feature that that you can
use yeah
it's oh there's a b okay so the fun
thing this next Warchief uh We've
unlocked now he's actually got a new
ability as well because it's not only
talian now that can be mounted it's also
the enemies as well we' got got enemies
mounted on the on the carag enemies
mounted on enemies mounted on enemies we
actually saw that the other day oh here
we go so now the ghouls now where do the
ghouls fit in in in Middle Earth lore we
it's sort of the they're sort of I think
they're really from the same sort of
origins in here as as the the Goblins
but they've really gone very degenerate
and very kind of nasty once again here
within Mordor they can they poison on
you the matrons do yes and that's
actually it's consuming these disgusting
toxic ghouls that's then kind of led to
the reactions that makes the The
Wretched
grow makes The Wretched grow so wretched
is his diet of uh disgusting ghouls but
the with with all of this the sort of
big overarching theme is they've got all
these disgusting and dangerous and
horrendous Powers but you've also got
the ability to take those and use them
to to your advantage against your enemy
as
well and The Wretched gr and those
enemies they're unique to this
particular story Miss yeah so yeah so
how can we Cur that mullet that mullet
is just too amazing we need to drag
their vile
Queen lord of the M look at him he's so
cute I like the M the little mutton
chops and the I think my favorite thing
in the in the main game is he still sort
of has these body image issues about his
gut so he what gut
I know this dwarf is
Rich he looks great you look great
torvin so now what we can do is uh can
actually in the same way before you
could hit the cages to let out the
caragors now you can hit the ghoul
mounds and actually summon these guys
out as well and once you've drawn them
out you're going to get the power to to
Brand them so before we can Dominate and
use Force you can dominate now we can
Dominate and develop our own Army of uh
ghouls this is amazing an army of ghouls
no
mat what we need to do first in order to
do that poison it's draining he'll be
fine he can take
it Mallet soaks it up worried about
grave Walker turning any of you against
me I could take a lot of you with my
eyes closed and one AR be on my back
ghouls down here okay there's the next
to gosh that's a scary little marker the
little like Scream face you have for the
GH yeah the ghouls are nasty the really
the idea was something that's just truly
kind
of um predatory and inhuman and nasty
really um calash wants to know can he's
calling it the mullet talian skin but
this skin you can use it and okay you
can use it in the main campaign mullet
Talan so that's what we're going to call
it now it's off have decided to turn up
as
well matron and all of the all of the w
Chiefs in the in the lord of the hunt
like there's no main campaign uh War
Chiefs mixed in with it it's like this
is like its own separate oh well you can
get all of the all of the full scope of
the Nemesis system and all of those guys
still you know um can exist within here
as well but the Beast Masters themselves
the boss guys they're they're exclusive
to the okay the Beast Masters have their
own little there's one of the mat
ecosystem take her down a matron these
are the sort of the they're um if you
ever seen naked mole rats I have seen a
naked mole rat so basically the ghouls
have a similar ecology to them in that
they these sort of matriarchal creatures
so the the matrons um are kind of living
down there controlling the rest of the
hive so they're so they're the big ones
and then all the little ones are likey
them and rule them and by basically
that's what's happening here if we can
defeat and take out the matrons that's
going to unlock the ability now to be
able to dominate and control uh ghouls
ourself
wow ghoul matron I didn't know that
that's like some really complicated
middlee ecology there well I think one
of the things that you know really does
differentiate middlee from I guess
generic fantasy is that attention to
detail whether it's history or whether
it's myth or whether it's obviously the
attention to detail of Nature and so I
think you know in in Mordor we really
wanted to to retain that and and like in
the films are such an inspiration for
that as well it's like not only within
Middle Earth but like Skull Island they
do such an amazing so here's a here's an
ecosystem that everything's trying to
kill everything and everything's kind of
ramped up to 11 um and so that was I
think a bit of a inspiration for what we
wanted to do you know Mordor is kind of
a lost world within middlee and even um
uh in the books where it's referring to
the origin of the Fel Beast it's like
creatures of a lost world maybe they
were so even you know there's that tease
or that hint that Mordor is kind of a
lost world the great beasts are there
there's these primitive creatures there
so World took that approach to you know
not only to the ORS but also to Nature
itself yeah I mean it's it it looks
beautiful right now but then of course
saon moves in and then sort of like just
wastes anything that's left the fun
thing is again even in the um the Sea of
ner so this still even later even during
the time of the war of the ring this is
the area from which he's able to feed
all of those vast armies and um then
after Aragon becomes king elisar he
actually gives this area back to the
slaves who've been tilling it as well so
but they've got like what's left at that
point like it's true yeah it's probably
going to be some of the the cheaper real
estate
ofar here I'm I'm going to bestow upon
you this great gift of good luck bit
moral yeah empty lands I mean at least
he you know gave him some land they can
figured out I'm
sure we got to kill the I really want us
to be able to get to uh I want to see
the Grog yeah we we'll we'll get our
ability to dominate these then we'll go
get a Grog and then we'll go and see
about which of these War Chiefs we can
we can take down as well
yeah oh there's one of um one of to's
journals he's left back in this cave as
well so you collect torin's journals and
they sort of they they'll embellish on
his sorry yeah um and a little you know
some of his thoughts and his oh look
them vomiting all over those guys there
she is oh look at that shadow strike oh
you've done it already Okay take her out
boom two down two one to go look at that
maton
head yeah it's fun getting to explore
some of his thoughts on talion and just
sort of his point of view on the world
as well
a I love the dwarves I love them so much
much you got to be looking forward to
the movie then world wars I already have
my midnight tickets I'm going to wear my
Hobbit cloak I am so
excited it looks amazing the trailer
looks fantastic I'm really excited to
see well I don't if you haven't read the
book by now I'll be I'll right I'll be a
little less spoilery but I love I can't
wait to see what goes on with smoke like
how they handled that whole
situation God I said how they handle it
I didn't say what happened
if you haven't read The Hobbit you
should really read The Hobbit It's PR I
want to see the other thing that I like
you know what they set up in the
previous of what's going to happen
around old gor and how they left all of
that that's going to be amazing The
Necromancer
yeah break the chains of the D I think
that that story as well is you know we
really do sit in between The Hobbit and
lot of the Rings so actually being able
to see the the conclusion of that story
and what happens with the Necromancer
actually makes it kind of an interesting
you know Prelude to what we get to do Oh
I thought you were going to get oh here
we go oh man that was that was brutal
there's probably a really good
opportunity for a good mullet shot
coming
up get it in the butt hit it see if you
can get it in the butt and get the
mullet in one shot that's the that's
your challenge Evan a butt mullet butt a
butt mullet this is it do it get it get
it get it yes you did it and photo
that's awesome I I love this photo mode
this is so photo Mode's amazing you did
it you got it where you m it God those
matrons look really nasty they
are but then so of course they are nasty
but getting thank you bra thank
you that's that should be one of our
trophies that unlocks but anyway
unlocked butt mullet y um I'm really
interested to see what they do with for
the movie with um Tel see how that how
that resolves itself
cuz she's not in the Lord of the Rings
what happened you know we'll see so I'm
very excited I think again there's that
inspir you know larel as we're talking
early wanting to have these sort of
strong women yeah she's
great I was really nervous about that
before the movie but I think they did a
great job nervous about toriel you know
T yeah I think we all were I think um uh
evangelene Lily was also nervous about
it she did all those interviews where
she was like I agreed to do it but only
if there was no romance involved and
then they called her back and they did
all the romance scenes so like I don't
know I think she does a great job with
it this guy's awesome I love this guy so
you know me not only now that we have
he's coer yep so we've got guys that are
riding um wa wait go back can you go
back to his thing motive lamenting how
hard it is to find a private place and
quiet moment with stompy is Stompy his
Grog oh yes do you want do you want to
meet Stompy I want to meet Stompy all
right let's go and meet Stompy oh man
that's cute that's cute I want to meet
meet Stompy all right let's go meet
Stompy this is
fun fasters were ever to become more
organized all have would be okay this
this will all work fine it's all going
to be fine are you confident you ready
you taking out Stompy everybody cheer
Evan on he's going to take out
Stompy meet Stompy oh to meet sty so
we've got all the torvin missions with
all the different um beasts then we've
got all the new war Chiefs and then if
we see the the white icon on the mini
map there's also a whole new set of side
missions and challenges great around all
the beasts and creatures and then okay
so what are the uh what are the the
runes like this the special runes that
you get for Lord of The Hunt ah there's
there's ones that um I'm not sure which
I trying to remember exactly which one
corresponds to which Warchief um but
there's ones that increase your power
while you're riding there's ones that
mean you can drain your ammo so you can
B basically shooting from um the back of
these guys is more powerful so they
really make you know the mounted combat
um much more powerful okay here we go
this is going to be funa coua so now the
skill that we've got which is being able
to draw in these kind of swarms of
ghouls is what we need to do in order to
draw out this Warchief so there's going
to be swarms of ghouls him stomping in
on Stompy on his uh so excited to see
Stompy are you guys excited for Stompy
I'm excited for Stompy I'm very excited
for Stompy
stpy just need
to okay one here he
comes draw out it's fun being able to
just um get the ghouls running rampant
inside the orc fortresses as well oh man
one
more they probably should have cleared
these nests out if they were a bit more
um or
organized and
three 1 to 10 orx kill BX with fited oh
we got one one died already they've
started swarming out once they start
swarming they're going to three wow
they're dropping
fast and then Stompy's going to have to
come out and check out what's going
on I'm so excited for
Stompy four should be oh there's matrons
coming out as well they're going to make
short work of these uh these ORS there's
a lot of
matrons oh wow oh and they're barfing
the poison
Yep they're actually even pretty
powerful against the um against the
grows once you get them to why one
more
okayu be is he here
Stompy
wow okay let's so now you have to take
down exactly wretched Gro Sho so the
great thing is if you can stun him
that's actually going to make uh the
ghouls leap on him and help you take him
down as well oh wow and they take extra
damage when they're stunned so so it's
really about kind of using all these
different creatures in nature uh hitting
them against each other oh man this is
awesome yeah
um oh no they hate the ghouls so which
makes sense so does this guy they all
hate the ghoul with uh with good cause
cuz ghouls are a menace to Stompy The
Grog down there tiny
down Kash one would like to know why UGA
UGA cuga has so much swag a lot of these
Orcs have a lot of Swag I'd like to say
he's uh he's definitely high up in the
Dark Lord's favor oh he started careful
poison I don't forget you've got your uh
game changers as well can use your sword
there Game Changer
Rune sh okay stun Stompy get
him show me your
skill the sword Smith M that was a nice
shot oh sorry I it just ran into the
pole and knocked itself out foolish
creature oh man okay nice oh need to St
stop they're like slow motion
talking look at those
ghouls okay so they are successfully
wearing down St oh no another one let's
see other Bodyguard iska the
fanatical I must deal with you both so
he's angry so he's TR worried about
dealing with these Ghouls and you at the
same time Stompy's down someone's got
some anxiety
issues jeez stomp recing you've got this
haven't you
stomp
oh oh good job stop he's got yeah he's
got all his own combat chatter as well
that's adorable in the face and
again okay he's down stomping there some
fire there but you don't want to burn
your own ghoul that's a
challenge something I probably should
mention is as well the um this DLC is a
little harder than the the main so is it
a little harder if you've uh sort of
completed the game and definitely if you
were looking for a bit of an extra
challenge um this is definitely but
hopefully not too much for Evan there we
go
perfect there we go he's coming back so
this stomp's nearly down
what oh they cool all
right so this has the difficulty level
has been kicked up would you say it's
really it's really the yeah the
intensity of what's going on in addition
to the you know abilities of these sort
of so these ghoul matrons even
one-on-one they're pretty tough and now
we've got hordes of these things
charging around so there's a lot of uh a
lot of chaos I kind of don't want Stompy
to die but he has want Stompy to die
stomp you no I even less want Evan to
die
but did we brand someone did we brand
someone we did we one can yeah yeah yeah
let's let's brand somebody ev's just
running now oh no no
stopy oh he's so sad and dead and UGA
kuga is so sad he's going to be sad
let's go
and oh and he's really angry he killed
uh-uh I hit that fire get
him a no it's going to take more than
that you don't get to have your own grow
by being vulnerable to stealth oh take
him oh
man St me hot
flashes nice my only friend I smash you
what have we done smash dead Stompy was
the only only friend Stompy was the only
one only one I he his last words as well
he's only one who understanded
understand understood wow writing words
Game Changer use your sword ah don't
die oh oh
that was so close click those sticks oh
oh no no no no no this is it this is it
it's fine it's fine it's totally
fine got this oh my god oh branding nice
yes lethal's challenge we don't want to
do this here it's a damn fine idea
that's it kill
him that's it take
him those are new trophies like that was
a new trophy DLC specific trophies
cool I
think okay he can do this no opportuni
in the environment he's nearly down you
can do this I know you can do it
Evan oh my God okay get him oh oh [__]
did I mention did I mention that this
DLC is a bit harder
yeah oh he he's panicking he already
knew that oh man oh no or at least that
hates run run run there's a can we Grand
The Shield guy
yes okay coun up ooh ooh ooh oh no uh
the rage there has actually restored
restored his health as well so when they
get enraged he's actually able to uh
restore his health and he's so angry
about the death of Stompy as well oh oh
no oh dear oh
oh no no oh oh oh brutal
brutal oh man oh
man oh that was brutal okay so I think
as I mentioned this one's a little bit
tougher all right oh my God I think
we'll go we'll go after some well we got
to see at least you got Stompy we got we
got to see Stompy so what we need now is
our own wretched grow we going to go get
one now yeah we should go get our own
one let's treat ourselves yes
treat ourselves get our own wretched gra
okay so we'll fast travel across this
Tower oh my
god oh that was
brutal thought you had him you were so
close so close and his his last words
are so heartfelt as well you killed my
only friend My Only Could you I feel bad
I do feel bad I feel remorse at killing
stopy okay obviously in the uh we will
be able to settle that unsettled
business yeah cuz he's now promoted yep
or he was a war chief or now his power
is higher this guy this is another one
of these um Elite War Chiefs and what
he's been all about is actually
Exterminating uh these creatures so of
course we don't want them all dead
because we want to use them so we'll
follow tovin exter um s Shir wants to
know if a if a a ghoul matron kills you
do they get more powerful or is it just
a ghoul killed you yeah yeah we don't
they don't actually have sort of
individuality they really are sort of
just uh
creatures but there is one of these War
Chiefs here who does have a sort of a
particular sort of friendship and
relationship with the the ghouls as well
um and again once again it's sort of
using them to bring him down but also
giving you the power to kind of Dominate
and use these creatures as
well oh wow so so not all of the Orcs
hate ghouls some of them are have a
symbiotic relationship all all of them
hate GS except this one sick and twisted
individual sick and twisted to be friend
ghouls I believe it yes him oh so I
should say two there's him and talion of
course who will use any weapon at his
disposal if it means bringing down s's
forces he is
persistent yes with that
mullet with the mullet now what are a
lot of a lot of different people are
asking this question what are Fel beasts
Fel Beast yes so Fel is like dangerous
um evil Wicked so sort of gets used the
main context that gets used in the book
is in is in regard to the big flying
creatures that the nasal are on the wi
beasts the winged they are winged Fel
beasts but F beasts are sort of wicked
and nasty and evil and dark uh
creatures so would you say that all of
the creatures within this realm sort of
fall
absolutely yes all right so fell they
all
fell I was actually looking in my Kindle
Dictionary at the definition of fell
just before in in relation to that it's
a word that comes up a lot so
now um not only can we use bait to bring
in caragors and use the nests uh to
bring in the ghouls we can there's also
bait with a very particular aroma for
grogs and not just any grogs theed
wretched GRS yes oh my God this is
awesome wow that was great you
teleported you did The Wraith jump on
yep so you can do the the shadow uh
Mount to dominate him but then once
you've got him we have to name him you
can't use Stompy that's already
taken do we name him what is he good at
uh he's very very good at projectile
vomiting what about Aussie Aussie was a
short for Australian we're also we're
also quite good at projectile vomiting
okay we'll call him aie aie The Wretched
Grog I was going to go with like barfy
or something bar would be fine as well
Aussie The Wretched Grog and so the um
you just pull the left trigger so it's
actually the rang mode while you're on
him so he really he really is like a a
tank
now
aie take take these guys and get
him oh
perfect gosh what did he eat he ate
ghouls this is what happens if you eat
ghouls so gross so don't don't eat goul
don't do that friends don't let friends
eat
ghouls oh my God there's so many of them
here but obviously if you're on a Grog
you can take out more like many yeah
yeah he's he's extremely uh effective
hold L2 and aim AR hold hold R2 to
projectile vomit yeah so it's basically
left trigger to aim right trigger to
shoot and he he uh Aussie becomes your
range mode oh my God this is awesome oh
I think that audio team just did oh my
gosh that I think that's probably one of
my favorite meetings of all time was the
audio meeting about what he should sound
like and just like more disgusting your
sound team went all out for that how
barfy and gross can we make
it can wretched grow at his so now of
course to go after the Warchief who's
the specialist in taking these guys down
we actually get to um
use so this guy is very and again can
you just go back to him for a sec he
again he's got a whole new set of
weapons if we go off to the right he's
got a totally new ability as well we so
he has rapid fire explosive um rapid
bomber yeah so he's got rapid fire
explosive projectiles so he's is
extremely uh intense and also
invulnerable to a whole bunch of stuff
so these War Chiefs are are pretty
pretty hardcore oh my God that's crazy
we should um maybe we'll go should we go
after well we we can pick we could go
after him and uh take Aussie we could
try I think we should leave the grow
grer um he's grieving yeah the Beast
Tamer is pretty cool Tom Horn Beast
Tamer he requires he's really all about
using the stealth of the caras so
prowling and hunting on the caras or
last but by no this guy's fun as well
he's The Smuggler so he's mounted so
this is about sort of chasing down and
hunting the the mounted um mounted
enemies on their carag what's in his
bag
stuff no he's got all sorts of stuff
he's like moving all sorts of illicit
Goods across M maybe we'll we can go
after him he's pretty fun let's go after
him I like I like his blood mask let's
go after him mission to to draw him out
to get to him kind of fun too
monstrosities of Mordor I must kill the
Butcher and keep the ORS afraid oh
there's one of torin's journal entries
as
wellin where is our
buddy he's waiting Meanwhile we're just
riding our projectile vomiting
grogs running around with
aie oh my God nothing to see here I like
how all of the Orcs are just like whoa
what
is okay so if we hop
off he just hanging out hang out there
hey
buddy chase down chase down and kill iic
corers we're killing mortar's Postal
System yep and they' only just establish
established it as well it's only very
recently that they've just managed to
get to ride these guys we're just coming
in and ruining
everything they're ruining absolutely
everything now these guys the thing
they're trying to smuggle is actually
explosives so the good thing about that
oh don't forget we need to use the speed
of the carag here and we also need to be
pretty precise shoot these guys in the
back that's it before they
deliver front G
FR that's awesome oh
oh man that's so cool they just go down
and oh don't let him get it you can do
it why did you run into the that's it
you've got him you got him you got him
yes good shot will unnown hav damn so
they're not delivering that okay there's
the next
one
whoa a little okay this
is really using the speed of these uh
new
mounts okay and oh man yeah this is is
faster than the oh oh
no you got to get that Rune that adds
that doubles your uh slow down time I
got that oh two in one that was
beautiful very nice you got him Evan's
pro at this yep oh good shot that was
awesome okay you got this and then the
thing we're also really able to do with
this one is the actual missions to draw
out the war Chiefs you know been able to
sort of blow them out and make them um
sort of a bit more expansive as well and
take advantage of all the sort of new
mechanics now you put in you you kill
them like you
can't you for the war Chiefs you kill
them you don't dominate them or are you
doing sort of the same thing were you uh
the goal in this yeah is but you can
kill you can kill or dominate but yeah
you got to defeat these guys oh last
one okay now The Smuggler has
arrived so I've actually there are a
couple of question questions in chat um
in the append the appendices of this
game mention great beats of
gorgoth yes well uh yeah they are oh
okay we need some more what are they uh
so the great beasts are the the big
creatures that we saw kind of dragging
grond dragging the big battering ram up
against the gates of M tith they're not
olifants they're something no I mean
sort of I guess what an olant is to um
is to an elephant so this kind of huge
monstrous version uh the great beasts
kind of out maybe rhinos or you know
really sort of massive uh Beast of
Burden so they're the things that are
actually they're kind
of basically the transport to move the
goods around um Mordor so we haven't
they're not actually here in the the Sea
of ner but we sort of wanted to use the
appendices to kind of even flesh out
more of the lore and flesh out um more
of the kind of ecosystem as well oh so
we've got The Smuggler we've managed to
to Dismount him but now he's down he's
also a monster Slayer oh my God look at
his face he got Cara gas pluged covered
in blood and he just he doesn't
care and he's going to deliver you all
across
Mordor oh this will give us our first of
our epic runes if we take this guy down
too as
douche everyone's favorite that was
perhaps the funnest to chant as well I
uh I actually encountered a war chief
named douche rat yes and it was funny
cuz when I found him I zoomed in and
then Alistair as Kell more well you know
say pronounce pronounce their name for
you so it zooms in and he's just like
douche rot and I was like I'm a child it
was great no I love
that was he like in the booth just being
like you want me to read this
yes in the old takra still had a little
fight he looks a little old he is the
elder he a long time in the old days men
had a little fight so again there's that
like the elves who knows how old these
guys are he could be thousands of years
old like that idea that some of them
have been here for a long time I don't
know if I'm I'm meant to talk about such
things but I found Alistair yeah um he's
he's married to Skyla of Breaking Bad
and a gun me saw that the other day I
was kind of nerding out in DB w
that's awesome cool and a gun is awesome
yes wow that's talk about power couple
that's really cool he did a and he did a
great job as Korey he was great I think
you know really got the sort of the the
gravitas of him but the villain of him
so and of course it's huge fun cuz we
got to bring him back for the the bright
Lord DLC so we really get to kind of
blow out on Kell bmbo and S on and their
kind of relationship to each other and
kind of you know so really excited about
that okay so we've we got our first of
our epic runes as well awesome which one
does what does this one
do okay okay oh sorry if we go we can go
slot that one let's go slot that Rune
let's slot our Rune see what it does so
how many uh new runes do you get with
yeah we've got five new epic runes yes
so the defiant one that was from the
free DLC today and then the carag one
okay so now whenever your mounted caras
if they're eating an enemy they're going
to they're going to regain more health
so that makes them uh they can tank much
more effectively okay that's really
awesome so there's a lot of uh you get a
lot of reward to doing the lord of the
hunt DLC whether it's the runes or you
learn more about torvin story which is
awesome um that's all we're going to
show you today what were you going to
say oh yeah and the trophies and the war
Chiefs and yeah a bunch of stuff
trophies War Chiefs lethel dwarves um
larel is available today uh Lord of The
Hunt will be available uh later this
year as part of the season pass
um thank you so much for coming and
hanging out with us and geeking out and
playing Shadow of Mordor um for more
coverage check out gamespot.com and
thank you for watching bye thank
you